last month we showed images of sleeping
staff at Wootton lawn a mental health
unit in gloucestershire and heard
stories of patients getting on the roof
wandering onto railway tracks one being
discharged then throwing himself off a
bridge minutes later
just walked out of the door jumped head
first off a bridge
and he had
smashed his skull smashed his face Had a
Brain Hemorrhage smashed two arms and
two legs and punctured his spleen the
NHS trust said it received positive
feedback but acknowledged they didn't
always get things right a year earlier
Sky News also gathered damning
testimonies from numerous patients at
Mental Health Services run by Hunter
coomb group I thought I went there to be
kept safe and I would learn new ways to
do to self-harm I don't feel they made
me any better I think they made me a lot
worse the group said it was taking steps
to improve its care but it's these
stories and others that have led to the
government launching a national
investigation into inpatient mental
health services the new health services
safety investigations body
will investigate the following themes
how providers learn from deaths in their
care and use this learning to improve
services including post discharge how
young people are cared for in mental
health inpatient settings and how this
can be improved
there is already an inquiry into nearly
2 000 deaths over a 20-year period in
mental health services in Essex when it
was launched some campaigners like
Melanie Leahy refused to take part
because it didn't have the power to
compel witnesses to give evidence her
son Matthew died at the Linden Center in
Essex how many more have to die before
the statutory powers are given two years
later the inquiry chair complained that
only 30 percent of Staff Witnesses were
freely contributing to the investigation
so now the health secretary has given
the inquiry the powers it needs to make
people give evidence you know this has
taken over 10 years of my life to get
this far the people that have helped
have been immense but we now need to
work so much harder now to get to get
this inquiry up and running with the
right terms of reference the new chair
and
um you know we're ready to start work
the scandal of Mental Health Care
failings have been slowly coming to
light and mostly through the sheer grit
and determination of those who've
suffered the consequences
Jason Farrell Sky News